I want to talk to you about the
government's policy on small boats it's
very clear they say that they want to
try and stop the small boats by saying
anyone who enters the UK illegally won't
be able to make a claim for Asylum would
a labor government keep that policy
we don't think it works I mean we want
to stop the small boats as well it's
just that we don't just want to talk
tough we actually want to take some
action and soella bravaman has said you
know that people are fed up with tough
talk and no action and she's right and
this legislation that they're trying to
pass is very similar to the legislation
they tried nine months ago and that
didn't work you know I like the
legislation from nine months ago they
identified 18 000 people who they said
had no right to be in the UK and how and
in the last year how many of them have
they sent back 21. you know this is just
rhetoric this is posturing and it's not
a plan so you're stopping the small bit
I'm just trying to work out do you
object to the government's policy purely
on practical grounds because you don't
think it will work or do you objective
or moral grounds too on principle I
think first first and foremost we want
to stop the small boats and we want to
take action that's going to work we
think that it is wrong that the
government is trying to posture we are
concerned about some of the languages I
think we could agree everyone wants to
stop the small boats but the principle
that if you enter the UK legally you
shouldn't be able to claim Asylum do you
agree with that well I think our concern
is that there will be amongst those
people some people who are genuine
refugees and there will be people who
are taking the Mickey and what we should
be doing is making decisions and making
decisions fast essentially we think that
we should have a a firm fair and fast
immigration and Asylum system but
instead what we've got is we've got
hotels clogged up we've got them wanting
to open up in all kinds of camps and
just lock people up in them if you were
let's say a um an interpreter for the
army in Afghanistan you know the people
who have been able to come out and get
Asylum have already gone you know the
helicopters have gone the planes have
gone people are now stuck and they've
been told by the government to make
their way to Britain and claim Asylum
but there isn't a way legally of coming
to Britain as an Afghan now well that's
so true though there is an Afghanistan
yeah
no no no it's finished it's not possible
to get I mean okay so so even it so so
yes you'd be able once you claim it then
you can claim but like where do you do
it and how do you do it the government
has said make your way here so if you
did make your way here illegally and
then claim
through the system I want that they go
no no sorry you've come illegally we
can't even process I think in
Afghanistan there is a legal route to
claim Asylum you cannot get from
Afghanistan to the UK legally so you
have to I mean there aren't any flights
you can't get there so you have to go
you have to make your own way to the UK
but not for Afghanistan though there is
a there is a resettlement program for
Afghanistan but they but the government
has said that people should make their
way because except from other countries
Syria for example Iran Iraq but for
Afghanistan there is you can argue about
the figures and the fact that very few
people have come under it but there is a
route a large number of people came
right a large number of people came but
then there was a cut off and now I mean
I have a constituent who's who went back
to get his wife and now can't get back
to Britain because there aren't any
flights and so he's having to take her
you know over into Pakistan and then was
hoping to try to get the two of them
into the UK but whether they're able to
get out of Afghanistan Enterprise
Pakistan is a big question you know
particularly given that he has a British
passport it's I mean the whole thing is
really very difficult and you slip into
you know illegally traveling very easily
very quickly in order to try to get
Asylum which is what people are doing
anyway
this is a longer side the point is this
right is that there will be people
amongst those who arriving in small
boats who are genuine refugees and the
government's policy now will be we don't
care you've come illegally we will put
you into a camp and you will have no
rights and we will well I don't know
what they're going to do I mean because
they can't send anybody back anywhere so
what what are they going to do with all
these people and they don't answer that
what they should be working on is they
should be working on a system whereby
they can return people and coming up
with some agreements with other
countries which is what they say they
are doing well they're not you know I
mean pretty Patel was banned from France
if you remember because of the remarks
that she'd made they were having
discussions and they said we're not
going to have your Home Secretary they
have you know the broken the broken
immigration and Asylum system is the
fault of the government and the
government have been in power for 13
years and they have broken it
um Gary lineker has the football
presenter has criticized the policy as
immeasurably cruel
do you think it's appropriate for
someone who works at the BBC who accepts
money from the license pair to use their
platform to make political statements
I know that Gary lineker feels very
strongly about this issue and he has
introduced I mean he's brought
refugees into his home he campaigns on
this issue I think some of the language
that Gary lineker has used in the last
24 hours has been really very
unfortunate and I wouldn't have used
some of those people talking about the
comparison to Germany yeah I don't I
just think that there is a special place
in hell for the Nazism for the Holocaust
I don't think that you should be making
comparisons
um so I wouldn't have said that I think
that he went too far but what the BBC
does about it is frankly not my business
it's not for me to time maybe see what
they do
um and um you know it'll be up to them
if they want to do anything about it but
otherwise I'm sure he will continue to
say what he thinks yeah it certainly
seems that he doesn't tend to do that
um I want to talk to you a little bit
about anti-Semitism because Luciano
Berger returned to the labor party four
years after stepping down accusing the
party of anti-Semitism under Jeremy
corbyn and Kristoff apologized for what
he described as her intolerable and
unacceptable experience do you agree
that she had an unacceptable experience
yeah
I just wonder because obviously both you
were in Jeremy corbyn's Shadow cabinet
you know you used to buy him you
campaigned for him you tried to get him
elected you also said at the time you
didn't believe that Jeremy corbyn was
anti-semitic do you think that by being
in that shadow cabinet you were part of
the problem
no I don't I think that I mean I
remember both Kia and I were constantly
pushing you know to make sure that we we
adopted the international definition of
anti-semitism you know I know that both
of us push that and I know that behind
the scenes we campaigned on it we we did
everything we could to ensure and
eventually succeeded in making sure that
the day party accepted that was the
standard you know we raised the issue
frequently in Shadow cabinet and we
don't normally talk about what happens
in Shadow cabinet but I mean I think
that enough time has gone by to be able
to tell you that it's you know he knows
and both and I know that he did too the
two of us would raise it frequently and
make sure that we kept pushing it we
kept saying what's happened to the
disciplinary process we want to have a
report when are we going to have a
report all of these things happened and
and making sure that we continue to push
it was a very important part you know if
you felt like that yes why did you then
campaign for Jamie Corbin to become
Prime Minister wouldn't that be a red
line for you I think that
I think that it was right for us to be
pushing that and I think that it was
right for us to try to ensure that the
party was was
dealt with that problem you know we did
fail but we did try
um I think that a labor government is
always better than a conservative
government I believe that to the bottom
of my soul that I think that labor
government is better I think that that
the way Jeremy led to the anti-semitic
one the way that Jeremy led the labor
party was was one whereby he would he
gave us quite a lot of of freedom to be
able to develop our own briefs and I was
Shadow foreign secretary at the time and
I don't believe that anyone can say that
our foreign policy was in any way
anti-semitic and I use made a speech at
Labor Party Conference
um and there have been before me
somebody speaking about Palestinian
cause and to a sea of Palestinian Flags
I said that there were people who
criticized Israel in a way that cloaked
their deeply felt anti-Semitism and that
that was a Scourge and that we had to do
something about it and we must the late
party and I got a standing ovation
because the vast majority of people in
the late party identified that there was
a problem and wanted it to be dealt with
um I am Keen as today's International
women's day to talk to you a bit about
that just to end the interview as well
it's a one issue I mean the thing is
there's so many issues aren't there that
you could decide to pick but I just
wonder if there's one issue that you
know you feel strongly about that's
personal to you that you think we should
be focusing on today
well yeah there are lots that's the
trouble
um so I think violence against women and
girls is a really important issue I
think that it impinges on all our lives
um and is it it intimidates us and and
uh and limits what we can do because of
a fear
um but I also think that yeah you know
50 years after the Equal Pay Act we
still don't have equal pay how can it be
that women still get 80 of the pay that
men get I mean this is a fact you know
women working full-time we're still
getting 80 why is that and it's partly I
think because you know when Barbara
Castle first introduced the legislation
it was like if two people are doing the
same job then they should both be paid
the same and that was kind of simple but
we've now got into much more complex
areas so we've got things like
like
um
the jobs may be slightly different but
they and therefore are paid differently
and of course there's always the man
who's paid more there's secrecy around
the amount of money that people are paid
it's really difficult to take your case
to a tribunal it's very difficult to
kind of say you know my job is this is
the same or similar to this person's job
and to get a comparison so how we value
classic women's work as well and then
there is the there is the difference in
so you know we saw this during the
pandemic didn't we we saw actually I
think it gave us an opportunity to look
again at what jobs we really value who
are the real core workers who are the
core employees and very often they are
women doing caring roles but they are
the ones who have paid the least have
you ever found
unequally in your career
oh that's a good question
um
yes I think there have been times when I
have not been paid the same that's
interesting um yeah no I think so name
any names
um no I mean I think that there were
times when I would do um so when I was
when I was a lawyer there was certain
work that I would be pushed towards that
would be paid less than the work that
that uh that men on the whole did and
then I started doing it and I turned up
and I would be the only one doing so
fraud cases for example I used to be the
only woman ever doing fraud cases and
they were paid much better than the
other type of criminal defense work that
I was doing and you know there were all
these guys in double-breasted suits of
me
um and that was unusual you know but
they had kind of cornered the market
although we were all doing criminal
defense work you know there were certain
parts of the of crime that that men
would do and women wouldn't really
interesting and thanks so much for
coming the program today not at all